this video is kindly sponsored by keeps
find out more later on hey 42 here in
may of 1997 in a museum in lucerne
switzerland
a security guard notices something
alarming one of the museum's paintings
is missing from its regular slot on the
wall
this is a small museum with only a
handful of guests visiting each day and
the security guard has just seen two of
them a man and a woman walk briskly out
of the front door
the guard sprints outside and catches
sight of the couple getting into a car
and sure enough the museum's missing
painting is sitting on the back seat as
luck would have it the museum happens to
be situated opposite a police station
and soon enough the thieves are in
custody
but at the subsequent trial it's clear
the man is extremely remorseful it was
he who took the painting a spur of the
moment decision he deeply regrets
since the man's criminal record is clean
he's released with a suspended sentence
serving no jail time nobody knew it at
the time but the swiss authorities had
just let the greatest art thief in
history
slip through their fingers
this is the remarkable story of stefan
brightweiser a frenchman who stole
almost one and a half billion dollars
worth of art to put that number into
perspective if you were to don your best
cat burglars outfit right now and nick
the three most expensive paintings ever
sold at auction leonardo da vinci's
salvador monday 450 million dollars
wilhelm de kooning's interchange 300
million dollars and suzanne's the card
players 250 million dollars
you would still need to pilfer another
half a billion dollars worth of art to
surpass stefan breitweiser's record
the sheer volume of arts to fan stole is
genuinely almost unbelievable but
perhaps even more unbelievable is what
he did with it all after he'd stolen it
but i'm getting ahead of myself for now
it's probably best if i start at the
beginning
and like all good stories
this one starts with cheese sort of
i want to take a moment to talk about
hair loss because i've had people close
to me start to lose hair as early as
their 20s and it's always been an
upsetting experience
if you're in the same boat then you're
not alone
did you know two out of three guys will
experience some form of male pattern
baldness by the time they're 35
but the best thing you can do to prevent
hair loss is take the initiative now and
do something about it whilst you've
still got hair left you used to have to
go to the doctor's office for a hair
loss prescription but now thanks to
keeps you can visit an online doctor and
get the medication you need delivered
directly to your door i like keeps
because it makes treatment super easy by
delivering your hair loss medication
every three months there's a reason that
keeps has more five star reviews than
any of its competitors and hundreds of
thousands of men trust them for their
hair loss prevention medication so if
you're like me you're probably not ready
to lose your hair just yet but
prevention is key the faster you act the
faster you'll see results and the sooner
you start using keeps the more hair
you'll save
if you're noticing that you're losing
your hair do something about it for a
limited time go to keeps.com forward
slash 42 or click the link in the
description to receive 50 percent off
your first order
in march 1995 stefan brightweiser was
visiting griez the swiss town that gave
its name to a kind of cheese you've
almost certainly enjoyed if you've ever
tucked into a traditional swiss fondue
but stefan wasn't in town for molten
dairy products
along with his new girlfriend and
catherine kleinklaus stefan had his
heart set on seeing gruyere's medieval
castle specifically its collection of
exquisite art as the couple strolled
through the ancient corridors one piece
in particular caught stefan's eye
a portrait by german painter christiane
wilhelm dietrich
staring at the painting stefan
experienced one of those weird urges
that we all have from time to time
a brief and intense desire to do
something we really shouldn't
something like jumping off a bridge
chipping up a passing pensioner or
stealing a painting
by the way don't feel bad if you
occasionally fancy downing and oap
these kinds of inappropriate urges are
so common they actually have a name
kakawi fees
for most people kakawi fees last a
couple of milliseconds
but stefan's lingered
so much so that he mentioned it to that
new girlfriend of his now i'd suggest
that admitting you're tempted to commit
a serious felony to your new tinder date
is usually a good way to earn yourself
the in-person equivalent of a swipe left
but to stephan's surprise
his new girlfriend was all for it
as far as art heists go this one wasn't
the most dramatic
the castle was basically deserted
apparently all the tourists were off
eating fondue and all stefan had to do
was remove the painting from its frame
slip the canvas into his rucksack
and walk out the front door
anticlimactic it might have been but an
international art crime career the likes
of which the world had never before seen
had just begun
because over the course of the following
six years stefan completed a grand total
of 239 successful art heists at
172 galleries in at least seven
different countries
so
how on earth did he do it i mean art
thievery isn't typically regarded as a
steady long-term career choice
sooner or later you're either going to
get caught or make so much cash that you
can retire to your own private island in
micronesia
if you're picturing grand heists with
oceans 11 style planning and huge teams
of specialists
you're dead wrong
there were no carefully or orchestrated
distractions
no detailed museum schematics and no
jaunts through conveniently positioned
air vents
in fact these heists
weren't even committed at night they
took place during opening hours and
often with tourists and security guards
in the very same room you see stefan had
noticed that the big galleries the
louvres and the momas of this world
have the kind of high-tech security
systems that make fort knox look like a
drafty hen house
small galleries on the other hand come
with all the security of a chunk of
swiss cheese
most rely on the general trustworthiness
of their visitors combined with an
assumption incorrect in most cases that
every painting and sculpture is bolted
down and rigged up to an alarm in short
outside of the famous few great works of
art are sometimes frighteningly easy to
steal not trying to give you any ideas
of course every one of stefan's heist
was a little different but all were
almost laughably basic pretty much
involving waiting till nobody was
looking and then simply picking up
whatever he fancied and walking out the
front door
paintings would be slipped from frames
and hidden under a loose fitting coat
and display cases were opened with a
screwdriver one twist at a time over the
space of 20 minutes or so
the most high-tech piece of equipment
stefan owned was an old telescopic radio
antenna which he used to prod any
inconveniently placed cctv cameras
into facing away from whatever it was he
was about to steal it's hard to believe
that's all it took for stefan to pilfer
close to a billion and a half dollars
worth of loot but these basic tricks
were so effective he was often able to
steal from the same museum multiple
times in the space of just a few weeks
using rudimentary disguises to ensure
staff at the museum didn't recognize him
it probably helps that god saw fit to
bestow stefan brightweezer with one of
the all-time great pair of balls
he was almost inhumanly cool under
pressure remaining calm even on the few
occasions he almost got caught i should
point out that estimates as to the exact
value of the artwork stefan stoll vary
but the figure most commonly quoted is
the one i mentioned earlier 1.4 billion
dollars according to the new york times
it might have been as much as 1.9
billion and if that upper limit is
correct as of 2001 when this remarkable
crime spree came to an abrupt end
stephan brightweiser art thief would
have been amongst the top 250 richest
people
on the planet
not that you'd have known it from
looking at him
in fact to the outside world stefan and
ann catherine now his long-term
girlfriend
appeared to be stone cold
broke
stefan worked sporadically as a waiter
and general kitchen dog's body
whilst anne catherine was a nurse
money was so short that stefan's mother
often helped the couple out with food
and petrol money was this apparent
poverty some kind of front then
a gus from breaking bad style cover
story to hide their immense wealth from
the outside world
actually
no
stefan and ann catherine
appeared close to destitute
because that's exactly what they were
despite having stolen well over a
billion dollars worth of fine art the
pair hardly had two cents to rub
together
and not because they'd blown their
riches on boats and hoes either
and here we come to what may just be the
most remarkable part of this whole mad
story
because despite having taken enormous
risks to steal hundreds of treasures of
almost unimaginable value
stefan bradweezer never sold a single
one of them
not
one
and the reason why is kind of hilarious
stefan didn't become the world's
greatest art thief to get rich quick he
did so because he loved art
instead of selling the pieces he stole
he kept them in the apartment he shared
with anne catherine
simply to have the pleasure of owning
and admiring them incidentally the
apartment in question was in the atticus
to fan's mother's house in the city of
mullhouse france
the couple were so poor they couldn't
afford to rent
and yet hanging on their shabby walls
strewn across side tables and piled up
in corners
was over a billion dollars worth of fine
art a collection that would have put
many of the world's galleries to shame
stefan was a remarkably successful thief
but it was this unique desire to own the
pieces he stole rather than sell them
that allowed him to operate for so long
you see plenty of art thieves are able
to successfully escape the scenes of
their crimes with their swag intact but
selling a world famous piece of art is a
seriously tricky business you can't just
set up an ebay listing and watch the
million pound bids roll in
the market for this kind of thing is
tiny and in order to access that you're
probably going to need to make friends
with some very dangerous people to help
you get the word out but getting the
word out about your recent highly
illegal art theft is arguably riskier
than the stealing part was in the first
place
which is why it's at this stage of the
process the sale that many art thieves
are ultimately caught and brought to
justice
since the fan never put a single piece
of art up for sale
he remained essentially invisible to the
police
if they didn't catch him in the act of
stealing they weren't going to catch him
at all the particulars of stefan's crime
spree were so unusual that the police
had basically no idea who or what they
were dealing with
i mean look at it from their perspective
an incredible volume of art was being
lifted from museums all across europe
the robberies always happened in
daylight and yet the thieves were never
caught
not to mention the fact that there was
complete radio silence from the black
market
and none of those pieces taken were ever
seen again their best guess was that
some kind of highly professional
international cartel was behind the
crimes
but in reality they were utterly stumped
if stefan had been content with a more
modest collection you know just a
billion dollars worth or something like
that
he might never have been caught
but it was his own insatiable appetite
that eventually brought about his
downfall
stefan simply couldn't stop and it was
only a matter of time before something
went wrong
the item that eventually ended his reign
of art based terror was of all things
a bugle
at the start of this video i mentioned
that stefan had been caught stealing a
painting in lucerne back in 1997.
he'd gotten away with little more than a
slap on the wrist at the time
but during the process of being booked
he'd had his fingerprints taken
from that moment on he'd been careful to
wear gloves during his thefts to ensure
he never left behind any prints that
could be matched to his earlier arrest
but while stealing the bugle stefan had
forgotten to don the latex gloves he'd
brought with him
if the police happened to dust the
bugle's display cabinet for prince
the game would be up
oh and by the way just to make things
even spicier this bugle happened to be
located in the richard wagner museum in
of all places
lucerne
the very same city he'd been caught the
first time
i told you this man had balls of legend
two days later stefan went back to the
museum to try and cover his tracks
the bugle job had been one of his rare
solo missions
so it was decided that anne catherine
should be the one to erase the prince
but this was a risky job and stefan
decided to travel with her for a bit of
moral support
as ann catherine entered the museum
stefan took a walk around the ground to
distract himself from worrying
unfortunately for him
he was recognized by a man who'd seen
him at the museum on the day of the
theft the police were called and
stephane soon found himself being
arrested for a second time
to begin with he wasn't unduly concerned
after all he'd been caught before and
gotten away with it all he had to do was
convince the police he was a remorseful
first offender just like he had the last
time
and at first that little ruse seemed to
be effective
but then
something changed
the officers holding stefan stopped
engaging with him and the sympathy his
remorseful idiot routine had earned him
evaporated overnight
stefan started to fear the worst and
with good reason
someone in the department had uncovered
the report from the previous theft in
lucerne
and as a result the police were no
longer viewing him as an opportunist
who'd snapped the bugle on impulse
but as a potential serial art thief
a few weeks after the arrest swiss
police secured an international search
warrant allowing them to enter stefan's
attic apartment in mullhouse
you know the one containing one and a
half billion dollars worth of stolen art
it's safe to say that as the team of
officers arrive to carry out the search
none of them were prepared
for what they would find inside stefan's
modest home
which was
nothing
no works of art lining the walls no
antiques no priceless jewelry
not even a bugle
just a bare attic apartment much like
any other
wait
what
[Music]
on witnessing her boyfriend being
apprehended by the police at the wagner
museum in lucerne and catherine had
immediately realised the dangers and
sprung into action driving back home and
alerting the one person every man can
rely on when really hits the fan
his mother and mrs breitweiser had
outdone herself over the course of
several days she'd gathered up every
single piece of art her son had ever
stolen
packed it all up into her car and gotten
it the hell out of there
anything that sank ended up in the
nearby rhone ryan canal and the
paintings
those centuries-old priceless works of
art
were burnt to ashes as part of what may
very well have been the most expensive
private bonfire in history
the last few odds and ends were
unceremoniously dumped in a nearby
forest
[Music]
had the rhone ryan canal been just a
little deeper stefan brightweiser
might once again have slipped through
the fingers of the justice system
but it wasn't to be
hikers spotted a curious twinkle from
the depths of the canal about a week
after the hall had been dumped
and the rest is history
police frogmen were called in to dredge
the waterway and close to a hundred
treasures from stefan's mighty horde
were fished out and catalogued
of course at this point the authorities
had no idea how all that stuff had
actually ended up in the canal but one
of the officers holding stefan in
switzerland got wind of the find and on
a whim decided to see if he could link
the treasures to his bugle thief
after all they been found not too far
from his home city during an
interrogation the officers showed stefan
a picture of one of the artifacts
recovered from the canal stefan had no
idea what his mother had been up to
since his arrest and so on seeing an
image of one of his most prized
possessions in the hands of the police
he reached the obvious conclusion they'd
searched his apartment and found his
horde the game was up
stefan promptly confessed to having
stolen the piece
matter of factly explaining when and
where he'd taken it
the officer was absolutely delighted
he'd figured this whole idea was a long
shot
but he'd hit the jackpot first time when
the next image he produced got the same
result an immediate detailed confession
from stefan
the officer could hardly believe his
look
what followed over the next couple of
hours was one of the most unusual scenes
ever played out in a police
interrogation room
stefan was shown image after image of
rare and expensive artwork stolen from
all around europe
and he confessed to having stolen every
single piece
never in their wildest dreams had the
swiss police thought that this one man
could have possibly taken everything
they dredged out of the canal
like all on his own and yet quite
clearly he had
so what punishment does a man receive
for stealing over a billion dollars
worth of art hands chopped off at the
wrists hung drawn and quartered
guillotined to the face
no
just three years in prison
stephane only served a little over two
of those his mother for her part in
disposing of the art served just 18
months and catherine hinting that she
too had been gifted with a fairly
weighty set of metaphorical balls
denied having any involvement in the
thefts whatsoever
in fact she claimed to have had no idea
stefan was even an art thief the court
probably wouldn't have bought it
but it seems stefan was happy to take
the bullet for his girlfriend because he
confirmed every word that came out of
her mouth
ann catherine was sentenced to six
months for receiving stolen goods but
she only spent a single night behind
bars
our story doesn't end quite there either
because it turns out prison did
absolutely nothing to reform stefan
bradweezer in 2011 police found more
than 30 works of art stashed in his
house
stolen naturally he was sentenced to
another three years behind bars and in
2019 he was arrested once again for
trying to sell a paperweight stolen from
a museum in san luis on ebay i know i
know he got sloppy
but hey sloppy or not stefan bradweezer
remains quite possibly
the greatest art thief to have ever
lived
thanks for watching
do you really enjoy my content but you
literally can't be asked to use your
eyes then you're in luck because you can
now listen to the new random interesting
facts podcast with me 42 available on
youtube spotify apple podcast or
wherever you get your podcast you'll
find a link to it in the description
below
check it out today and give your eyes a
break
you're welcome